welcome back i had to run out and get a
haircut and change my shirt but uh we're
ready to go
so we were just talking about k-means
clustering and remember one of the
things with k-means clustering one of
the challenges is you have to choose a
number of clusters k right
which is it can be a problem and a
little later we'll talk about strategies
for choosing k
but uh in this segment now we'll talk
about hierarchical clustering a
different kind of clustering the second
major one
that we'll talk about and it has
advantage it doesn't require the choice
of k as a matter of fact as we'll see it
gives us the clusterings for all k at
all at once
um and we'll talk about what's called a
gallometer or bottom-up hierarchical
clustering which is the most common kind
of hierarchical clustering there's also
top-down hierarchical clustering you
might see
but we won't talk about that in the
lecture because the the bottom up or
glomerulum is by far the most common
and we'll see that the agglomerative
the
clustering starts from the
bottom the the individual observations
as leaves and combines them successively
in a hierarchy
so let's see the main idea just in a
picture so here's some data with five
objects
and two features in the horizontal
vertical axis
and what hyper clustering does is it
successfully joins the each the closest
pair of objects so i'll first of all run
through it quickly and then we'll go
back and look at the operations more
slowly so here's the data and i'll see
what hierarchical clustering does
so there's one linkage and another
another clustering another one and
another one so i did a total of one
two three four joints
let's go back more slowly now and see
what happened so starting with the raw
data it looks for the closest pair of
objects
in terms of square distance we'll talk a
little bit later we can actually vary
that use a different a different metric
but usually it's square distance so the
closest points in the plane here the
closest pair are a and c it joins those
together
then it looks for the next closest pair
and that is d and e right
and then it's going to join the next
closest pair but now the idea of a pair
we're going to we're going to join not
necessarily always just single
observations we might join an
observation with it with an existing
cluster or maybe join two clusters
i'll have to decide on what we mean by
how far apart our two clusters which
we'll
we'll talk about a little later in this
segment but let's let's uh
let's see how we've made some choice of
that of that metric and let's see what
happens
it joined b with a and c
okay
and then finally
all five
points together in one question
so then in this last one i joined two
clusters together exactly
the big red cluster in the green cluster
right so this next slide summarizes
now the clustering again you see here on
the left the series of of
joins that we just saw
and now
on the right
is a dendogram or clustering tree which
is a a very nice way of summarizing the
clustering the the picture on the left
is fine when you have two features but
imagine if you had if you're you have a
hundred features we'd have to be drawing
a 100 dimensional object right
which you can't do uh the clustering
tree on the right is a um
the most useful way of summarizing the
clustering so let's see what's how it
summarizes things well here's the ac
first of all the bottom we have the
leaves of the tree the objects
labeled a through e
the first join is indicated here this is
the joint of a and c
and the height of the join is also this
height of this joint is drawn at the
height at which
is
at the
the distance between the two points
involved right so a and c
their square distance is
here and that's the height at which this
is is drawn the next join is d and e
then b with a and c and finally all the
objects together at the top
so the clustering tree gives us a a nice
summary of the the series of joins that
we get in the in the clustering but what
what does it mean a distance between a
point and a cluster right well we'll get
to that you want me to tell you right
now no no okay
okay
um
[Music]
so here's an another example there's uh
45 observations again two dimensions
and in reality here we've we've imagined
there's three classes so i've i've i've
colored them as such green purple and
gold
but we're not going to use these class
labels in the clustering we want to see
after we do the clustering where these
points end up
so here is the result of hierarchical
clustering to the 45 points and these
are all all the same um
dendogram but what i've done here is
i've um
i've cut off the the question tree at
different heights on the left i've
basically cut it off at the top so the
entire tree is one cluster okay that's
why i've labeled all the leaves by the
same color green
but here
i've cut the the question tree off at
this height well about nine it creates
two clusters which i've indicated by red
and green
and then finally here i've chosen a
different cutting height around five it
chooses it forms three clusters
the purple the gold and the green and
you see the original three classes which
i colored are are actually
coincide with these three clusters so
the point is that by t by by doing the
hierarchical clustering and cutting the
tree off at an appropriate height we
recover exactly the three classes we
started with
you can also see that now what this is
showing us is that with a single
operation giving us this clustering tree
we get the
a clustering for all k
right if we decide we take the same tree
if we cut off at the top we get k equals
one
we cut it off at nine we get k equals
two we cut it off here we k equals three
i could cut lower
and get more clusters i could cut it
right at the bottom and get a cluster
which had a cluster for each observation
which probably wouldn't be very useful
but the point is that we get a spectrum
from one up to n clusters depending on
where we cut from a single clustering
tree
okay so this is the the details of the
figure which i have already been through
okay so now we talked before about how
we had to decide whether how far apart
two clusters were or a point from a
cluster
the linkage is what that's called and
now um let's talk about the details of
the detroit choice of linkage so on this
slide i've got the different linkages
complete single average and centroid in
their definitions but i think it'd be
easier to go to a blank slide and i'll
have my khan academy moment
and show you um just in pictures what
these what these um
these measures are so complete linkage
that's first of all i think we have
imagine two clusters
okay and this guy's already a cluster
and over here we have another cluster
and now we want to decide how far apart
is this cluster of three from this
cluster of two
complete linkage
first of all the first kind
we look at
um
the farthest distance between any pair
where pick one object from here and one
from here so the farthest distance will
be
um
will be this one
right this pairs are farther apart so
the
um
we deem these two clusters to be this
distance apart that's complete linkage
so it's kind of a worst case measure
single leg which is the other one it's
the it's the best case we find the
closest pair and for that looks like it
would be this pair right this very
closest
that's single linkage
and then the average linkage is as you
can imagine if we take that we look at
all pairs and take the average distance
so we look at the distance between this
guy and these two and so how many all
together two everything are six i guess
six distances
the average of those the six pair of
white distances would give us the
average linkage measure
okay yes six six
he's quick okay and then the uh so
these are the three
first three measures the last one is
called centroid linkage which is
not used as commonly but you don't have
different colors in this painting uh-huh
actually i do have different colors um
well okay centroid linkage
we take the centroids of each cluster
first that's the average right the
middle point
there we go
um anything stable oh i don't wanna
okay
and now
so
these points are meant to the average of
these three and this one the average of
these two the centroid
linkage is how far apart the centroids
are these two
so that's the third measure
the ones that use the most commonly are
complete and average okay single linkage
if
you have a look at this
in our book there's a some examples of
it single linkage has a problem that
tends to produce long stringy clusters
so it tends to join one point at a time
as a cluster whereas complete and
average tend to produce trees which are
they're more more balanced more
symmetric looking
centauri linkage is common in genomics
it has some problems though with called
inversions which we won't discuss but
you can read about in the book
so there's there's four choices of
measure with complete and average being
the most commonly used
great one picture tells it all yes
and but if you want details the previous
slide has all this in
in words
let's see
okay
so
a few more things to talk about
um we talked about the uh the complete
average in single linkage and centroid
in the previous slide and that was to do
with how we deem how far apart we deem a
pair of clusters from each other
um but then we still have to we we want
to we have to decide what do we buy far
apart right and we would be using square
distance up to now and that's the
euclidean distance and that's actually
the most commonly used measure but
another one that's used quite commonly
is correlation okay which
is the correlation between the
the profiles
the features across two observations
across their features
this is often the case when features are
actually measurements at different times
so you can think of each series each
measurement for a not for an individual
as a series of points over time little
time series like each of these curves
and you want to see how similar the the
patterns are in each of those series so
then correlation measure is suitable in
that case so here's here's an example
and we can imagine this index as trevor
said could be time there are three
observations the purple the gold and the
green
in terms of square distance if we look
just across the coordinates the purple
and the gold are very close together and
the green's farther apart from those
those two in terms of correlation if we
just consider the pairs of points at
each of these
indices
then actually the green is closer to the
gold than it is to the purple right
because the green and the gold go they
go
down and up together right
um so the point is that if your
correlation doesn't worry about the
level but rather the shape
so if shape is in your in your example
is
a particular problem is more important
than the actual level then the
correlation
correlation is a better choice in
euclidean distance
and sometimes and also you have to
decide whether you want to use
correlation or absolute correlation
sometimes it matters whether things are
anti-correlated or positive correlated
other times
you just use the absolute value of the
correlation
so those are all common those are both
i suppose this brings up the point that
you can actually come up with any
distance that suits you right you know
depending on the problem if there's a
particular distance that makes more
sense exactly to use that it's like the
only thing you need for our clustering
and actually for k means for that matter
is a choice of distance between our
pairs of observations having decided
that then the algorithms just use that
as their input
okay
so some practical issues
a few more things well scaling of the
variables matter right and again that's
the case of in k-means as well so this
slide actually refers to both k-means
clustering and hierarchical clustering
right and principal components for that
exactly right if the variables are not
in the same units and
one variable is a unit that has very
large numbers right
then
if you don't standardize the variables
that that variable will dominate either
principal components
or clustering right because it's this
these the units are are such that the
the
square distance for that variable is
much larger
so typically if variables are not in the
same units one should standardize them
in other words take the mean make the
mean zero and variance standard
deviation to be one
if they're in the same units you have a
choice
um and it's it's often good to do it
both ways they're in the same units you
might want to leave the variables as as
is and see which which ones have more
variation and those will tend to drive
the principal components or clustering
um other what but
in other cases
people will standardize in that
situation so it's good to try it both
ways
and then in the case of hierarchical
clustering we talked about these already
should we use square distance or
correlation for dissimilarity and the
linkage right choice of linkage
um a problem i've alluded to i'm not
gonna get much of a say much more here
is the choice of k the number of
clusters right
uh and let me just say it's we're not
going to talk about it because there's
no it's a difficult problem with no
agreed upon solution there's not a
standard method we can point you to to
say this is how you choose k
uh in our
our data mining book the elements of
cisco learning in chapter 13 there's
there's much more detail about this
um but typically the problem is again
it's not well solved and it's it's
usually done in sort of a qualitative
way like for for a clustering
hierarchical clustering people just tend
to to
look at the result of the clustering
tree see where the
the biggest drop in the branches is and
maybe maybe cut it off there like we saw
remember the example
and go back just to the clustering
in this example right
you might
if you this was actually some data you
had you might look at this and say oh it
looks like the
the
the longest branches are here here's
where the longest arms are i'll cut it
off here and then below that the
the arms are much shorter right and
remember that's reasonable because the
height at which we draw these joins is
the
the squared
square distance at which the joins occur
so
the biggest bang for the buck is
occurring in these joins and then
there's less lower down so that's
subjective but that's typical people do
they just
have a look at this and say oh i'm gonna
cut it off you know maybe at three
clusters
okay
um
and which fish which feature should we
use to drive the clustering right you're
often given
some areas of science given a large
number of features
and you can
you want to use those features for
clustering some objects you can choose
the features you use and if you
if you change the choice of features as
you can imagine it's going to
change the classroom that you get
okay that's the end of this segment on
hierarchical clustering in the last
segment we'll talk we'll see a real
example of the application of
hierarchical clustering to a cancer of
study of breast cancer